my buddy steve smith back here on the
show how are you Steve well Steve you
know uh you know where my allegiances
lie on the football field having grown
up in New York City and quarterbacks out
with mono so I know I fell one
what do you want to know my response
sure the floor is yours Steve Smith no
Steve Smith turning down contact to
begin this edition of several
inappropriate things I ran through my
mind I just said tragic I know
I mean it's and it is but it is
potentially for the Jets season I mean
it's the Browns this week right and then
it's the Patriots the following week and
this is one of those debilitating
illnesses he I mean this this could
really put a linger for a long time
right so what do you think's going on in
that Jets locker room right now Steve
well I I think the good thing about
what's going on is they already know
management knows with the new coach
coaching staff with the new general
manager they know it's a process the
real question is will the powers that be
really understand that this is a process
and the biggest elephant in a room is
defense will they be allowed will they
allow themselves to really relax and say
hey even though that you had high
expectations will let bail in that
acquisition you still have to understand
and it still you got a young quarterback
you know this team has not what the head
coach and general manager they they have
not ingrained their philosophy
completely because they haven't had a
full offseason yet they still have to
allow some of the acquisition some of
the draft picks of the past that was
from the old regime
figure out who's who needs to stay and
who do you need to move on from or as
the business world says go in a
different direction and then on the flip
side you got the Browns I had Derrick
Henry on the show in our number one he's
one of the many Titans that delivered
the punch in the mouth I mean they got
hit in the mouth by Tennessee and a 40
burger is what the Titans put on
Cleveland in if any game won similar to
the Jets with so many high hopes that
went in a totally different direction
how do you think they're gonna respond
to that in Cleveland Steve the players
I guess the players because you know
they're the ones who committed 18
penalties and now loss - well we don't
we don't really know how they're gonna
respond down on paper and with words and
unfortunately you know you get a mic
putting it in your face and you have to
search for words - one that place blame
not finger point and not have account
building on yourself because you played
a role into that loss no matter how well
you you did you're a part of the loss
because that's part of being the T but I
I ask work network to go to Cleveland to
observe their training camp because I
wanted to see for myself what was this
team about and here's what this team is
when I think of that Cleveland Browns I
see them as a all-star it's like an
all-star game everybody's gone score
points but very few people gonna play
defense and you and all that defense
coordinator Steve Wilkes Freddie kitchen
the head coach and Cole offensive
coordinator they have to figure out
which guys will do a little bit of
defense which guys won't which guys what
routes can they run and which routes
they cannot Odell Beckham is a
phenomenal wide receiver but there is
probably a route that he doesn't run as
good as Landry and vice versa
and it takes some time to figure that
all out and unfortunately they're going
to have to figure it out in the game
against their opponents because that's
the only way you know that's the only
way you could figure out what someone's
made of and what deficiencies and what
great things they do is by baptism by
fire is really experiencing on-the-job
training and in terms of not play
defense you mean just do the all-around
game right not that not actually please
I just mean not actually play because
just all-around game because you only
watch NBA all-star game yeah you know
there's defensive player you know
there's defensive players of the of the
year on that team whether all-star game
is about scoring points is about the the
finesse the razzle and dazzle and when
you look at the lineup and the guys on
paper they can while you but in a
football game sometimes you'll need a
guy that's gonna Lao you sometimes you
need a guy who's just gonna stuff and
stop the run or get after the
quarterback and so you got to figure out
you know who's those guys and who can do
what who can Steve Smith here in the
Rich Eisen show and before we do move to
the game that you're in town for all of
you live there but that's about to say
that you're that you're in town to work
tonight
before we get to that what did you think
of Odell on the watch and all this stuff
that's going on with his wristwatch
well everybody talks about he's a
distraction first of all I am I'm
shocked how fast it went from a 500,000
at 350 to 190 yes um thousand dollars
that you know this shows you how how
much we just shoot out numbers I don't
think the watch is a big that huge of a
deal because here's the thing if someone
asked me to wear watch exact amount of
dollars I don't necessarily think I
would say no or yes I would think about
it but here's the thing I you know I had
this I said this I want to watch pretty
much first 15
first seven years eleven years of my
career there was a different kind of
watch but I wore on my right hand I wore
wristband you go back in 2007-2008 you
see I wore a white wristband and under
that I had a watch what was that watch
it was a look it was a heartrate monitor
and I had a heart rate monitor under my
pass and I had it on my wrist and I'll
put a watch up with the wristband only
because a few times the practice I broke
the watch mm-hmm
and those polar watches are expensive
150 bucks and if you go through three or
four of them then you know that's quite
a bit of money just to be wasted money
and so but why I right where it is I
trained with it as well and my trainer
would we would simulate how the game was
and why is that important my heart rate
at the height of a play after making up
a play my heart rate would be 225 beats
per minute geez and so I looked at that
as a way how fast did I was I able to
get my heart rate down and I trained
that way so what I trained now trading
at 180 a heart beats per minute and then
we would see how long it took my my
heart rate to get down right now I know
it's different but all I'm saying is
this is the point we all have things
that we need we feel we need to do our
job and if it's watch I just always wear
you know I'm bald
I swear earrings at 28 years old I start
to lose my hair so my hair just like a
model coming out of that swimsuit model
coming out of the water with their hair
yeah knocking up my score a touchdown
going to sideline I take my hat off my
helmet off and that's like me waving my
hair coming after I got water that those
earrings shining off the Sun man I mean
I we all have it I know rich you have
some things that you must have in studio
that's a certain thing about you that's
what makes you great why you've been
doing what you've been doing but you
have some little things from quirkiness
that you have to have we all have
and his just happens to be a hundred
ninety thousand dollar watch listen you
you got that nice uh minivan you didn't
turn that away from there I don't see
you dragging yourself watch it take it
no thank you
yeah you had me looking at one uh yeah
did you get the Honda Odyssey Steve did
you get one did they give me a free one
now Incan Steve Smith here on the Rich
Eisen show alright let's talk about the
receivers in King Carolina you know this
past summer the All or Nothing series on
Amazon you know it certainly grabbed a
lot of attention that you told DJ more
in front of him at a practice that you
were gonna bench him in fantasy would
you would you start him in bench him
okay I just asked should I start him
okay and I'm not a guy that likes to
talk about people behind their back and
I was joking me and DJ have a great
relationship we talk a lot mm-hmm
and so I was joking around with him
because we're still filling each other
out and there was a point where he kind
of thought I was really like being
around or trying to talk to him because
I had alternative motive and I have more
motive I just I love the kid he's here
in the city that I live and do business
and and and on the team that I used to
be also I'm personally excited to see
how well he can do and do you start him
in fantasy this week would you start him
tonight if you had him well
unfortunately I would start Christian
McCaffrey because he's only God is
getting past us
so I mean that's just how it is I'm all
I got to do my job and I'm still waiting
for this wire receiver crew to show up a
little bit because Chris McCaffrey is on
pace to have a thousand yards receiving
and a thousand yards rushing I person as
a former as a former wire receiver I
would have a problem with they think
that the only playmaker on the team are
the tight in the tight in and in the
running back
so I think it's a challenge for these
guys and we're gonna see we're gonna see
what Curtis Samuels and DJ more are
really about
and this Carolina petawatt receiver crew
is really about because last year they
were young they let go all their
veterans now this is their team but it's
actually not just Christian McCaffrey
team well I'm and I'm not saying this to
sir anything up is it the scheme or is
it the triggerman that might that might
be focused on McCaffrey well that's a
person right question
um well Cam Newton only is only gonna
throw it to the guy who's okay right
so people talking about he's not pushing
the ball down the field well do you
throw the ball to to someone that isn't
open or do you talk to the guys are open
i watch to fail they were you know they
got open sometimes but you work with why
we she was all the time most wide
receivers you know always what rich open
okay or vocal oh yes I don't see I don't
see them boys complaining that they're
open that's because they aren't mmm see
tonight you're gonna ask it
you're gonna ask Cam Newton a force of
past 20 yards down the field to a guy
who's covered what you think they got
well done is this is this is Jameson's
career on the line I don't mean to sound
alarmist but week one sounded terrible
this is his fifth fifth season walk year
here as you know Aryans is a guy who
doesn't mess around and this is going to
be his last go-round as an HC in the NFL
it appears so what do you think I
believe how come what's his cap number
for this figure it's about 20 million in
change about twenty point nine million
Steve 20 million dollars in your fifth
year and we're asking is he a franchise
quarterback in business you know I mean
basically where they do take the cash
put it in a bucket cut the hole out of
the bucket and pull all the money in
there because they're getting no return
on their investment
how many times have we seen non
quarterbacks get maybe a year or two
don't perform and get cut five years
three head coaches three different
coordinators do are we seeing a trend
lovie smith der cutter now the
quarterback whisperer
three coaches twenty million dollars
five years haven't lived up to the
expectation at some point you know you
have to ask us here liability or asset
based off last week I'm hitting on more
of the liability but he has hopefully a
couple more weeks to decide that he's
going to turn us around and become and
that's that yeah that's a big game
tonight it is a big game tonight for
Tampa it's a big game tonight obviously
for Jameis and obviously all of us at
NFL Network exclusive on the net and at
NFL gameday kickoff at 6:00 Eastern Time
colleen wolf Joe Thomas Michael Irvin
and you and I have been told a birdie
has told me a great feature involving
you Steve and the dream on three
Foundation where you took a young young
man named Brevard Wright junior who is
suffering from epilepsy to the game last
week is that a true rumor sir that was a
true rumor I was I was I was asked and
inquired about through dream on three I
work with them down here in Charlotte
they're a great organization they
basically kind of had that same
wheelhouse of make-a-wish
not everyone has life-threatening
illnesses that they work with but a lot
of them do a lot of them have silh
masseurs and so he came across my desk
and said hey this is kid Babar he loved
you as a football player and wants to
throw your packs I'm like well I'm no
longer football player but how can I
honor this young man who looks up to me
so we sat there and sat here and started
a me and some folks started kind of
trying to figure out call calls
called the folks at work they said hey
I'm not a football player but Kim we
allow him to hang out with me and so
last week for the first game drove up to
his house gotta work with the Panthers
gotten some tickets him his family his
mother his dad his two sisters and so
they got him a car service and so what I
told him I said man listen what's going
style picked him and his dad up went to
the game we parked got on the sideline
he could most imagine is Peppers coach
Rivera Kris McCaffrey and he told me to
pass but he also got to meet the new
owner mr. Dave Kepler and we just hung
out and talked he stayed for the game I
had to go watch all the other games and
then now today he is shadowing me on the
set as well I was that rice oh yes he's
shadowing me on the set as well because
I'm not a football player so he want to
go to the Panthers game let's make that
happen
easy peasy lemon squeezy but now let's
go ahead and see how Steve Smith the Nam
football player goes about his day today
and so he's gonna join us I believe on
the set today that's amazing but he's
gonna be hanging out with me today the
rest of the day so he went to the game
last week and then he's hanging out this
week at the game and so three more three
gave me an opportunity to love on him
and give him opportunity and make his
wish come true and it's been I've had a
blast and what is really done it has
allowed me to recenter myself and
realize men support sports is a conduit
to do a lot of different things and it
helps a lot of other people and when I
get the opportunity with all the
nonsense set aside the human element of
it the dad in me the husband I tried my
very best to take the speed Smith senior
football player out and be Steve on
Smith senior demand
the husband the co-worker in a way the
same way you Marshall Dion sometimes
Michael yes love one love on me and
teach me and guide me because you guys
my mentor
I'm younger so you guys are showing me
the way and so I'm just trying to pay
forward like how you do with st. Jews
and just all the things that you do I'm
I'm just trying to trying to follow your
footsteps big bro well Steve you are the
man and I'm glad again the Steven Smith
that you mentioned we've all seen it we
all see what a family man you are and
how you put your kids first we were at
that NFL 100 kickoff as well in New York
you had your family with you and it's
great to see that on display that'll be
on tonight's NFL gameday kickoff you're
the man Steve Smith you know you are the
man rich I'm just a squirrel trying to
get some of your snacks I have a great
cast tonight Steve I look forward to
seeing Brevard out there with you take
care you got it Steve Smith senior Steve
on four more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app